Michelle is an urban cyclist in Los
Angeles today I challenged her to take
the specialized turbo levo into the
mountains with me to show her a preview
of the world that an electric mountain
bike can unlock
do you like how it looks it's really
beefy
what do you think so far
it probably kind of pushes you off not
too not too crazy but it's pretty cool
it goes pretty fast and so off we went
on to a beginner friendly dirt path
behind my house
[Music]
so what do you think about the
specialized levo Michelle
yeah this is fun
honestly these feel so crazy
the downhill I'm not used to how smooth
it feels it's so much fun
I'm glad Michelle accepted the challenge
yet another example of how much an
electric bike can unlock in someone's
life Bank specialized